president Trump is in the Miami area
this morning for his first fundraiser
since the official launch of his
re-election campaign the president held
a kickoff rally with thousands of
supporters in Orlando last night in a
speech that resembled 2016 he talked
about voters fears and slammed Democrats
he said electing a Democratic president
would lead to quote the destruction of
the American dream mr. Trump won Florida
in 2016 by just over one point narrow
margin and a recent Quinnipiac
University poll finds Democratic
frontrunner Joe Biden is leading mr.
Trump in Florida by nine points it also
shows the president trailing other
Democrats in that state our chief
Washington correspondent major Garrett
spoke exclusively with the president's
campaign manager Brad parse kale who
claims that polling nowadays is flawed
severely the country is too complex now
to just claim what you mean I just think
the country is too complex now just to
call a couple hundred people and asking
what they think
there are so many ways and different
people that are going to show up the
vote now the way turnout now works and
abilities that we have to turn out
voters it's not it the polling can't
understand that that's why it was so
wrong in 2016 it was 100% wrong nobody
got it right and not one public poll and
the reason why is it's not 1962 anymore
it's not a place where there's only a
few ways and decisions and every line
lines up to vote like you know a good
old American now there's a lot of
distractions from you on the vote the
world's change in other late polls mean
anything it's the biggest joke in
politics it's the fakest thing it's the
fakest thing then why do they get in the
president's craw I get to ask him that
they don't know and because this because
I mean because the media makes it look
like they matter they don't then why
does he care I think because I mean I
don't know you have to ask him that
meanwhile Trump campaign internal
polling they're still using polling even
though apparently part skill does not
believe it works but they are polling
and the internal polling showed the
president trailing potential Democratic
rivals in several key states the
campaign says the polls were intended to
show a worst case scenario I always like
the answer just ask him that okay well
we would love the opportunity to do
exactly that